- [Narrator] Have you ever
been minding your own business
enjoying the sun when
someone steps in front of you
and blocks your sunlight?
This is pretty much what
happens during a solar eclipse
except on a planetary scale.
As earth revolves around the sun,
the moon revolves around earth too.
Once in a while, the sun, the
moon and earth all line up
so that the moon shadow falls onto earth
causing a solar eclipse.
During a solar eclipse, the
moon blocks the sun's light
and energy from reaching part of earth.
So how does a solar
eclipse appear from earth?
Well, if you're standing in the
center of the moon's shadow,
you'd see the moon appear
to completely cover the sun's disk.
This is called a total solar eclipse.
There are other types of solar eclipses
but we're going to focus
on total solar eclipses in this video.
During a total solar
eclipse, the outermost layer
of the sun's atmosphere
called its corona is visible.
On a non-solar eclipse day,
the Corona is invisible to us
because we can't see past the bright light
from the sun's surface.
Remember to never stare or look at the sun
with your naked eye,
binoculars or a telescope.
Looking even for a few
seconds can cause severe
and permanent eye damage.
Just because you can't look
directly at the sun doesn't mean
that you can't enjoy watching
a solar eclipse, though.
You can watch the eclipse in
action through a pinhole viewer
or ultraviolet ray blocking
solar eclipse glasses.
If you're in the moon shadow
during a total solar eclipse,
you might also notice
a drop in temperature.
On average, the temperature
drops about 5.5 degree Celsius
during a total solar eclipse.
This is because the
moon block solar energy
from reaching earth.
Total solar eclipses
last only a few minutes.
This is because the moon is
always revolving around earth.
As the moon keeps on moving,
the sun starts to reappear
around the moon and
eventually the sun returns
to its usual round and sunny self.
But how is it even possible
for the moon to appear to block
the sun in the first place?
The sun and the moon aren't the same size.
In fact, the sun is so big
that 64.3 million moons
could fit inside of it.
However, coincidentally,
the sun is far enough away
that the moon and the sun
appear to us earthlings
to be the same size in the sky.
So when the moon moves
between the sun and earth
during a total solar eclipse,
it appears from earth
to cover the disk of
the sun almost exactly.
Total solar eclipses
like all solar eclipses
happen only during a new
moon which is the only time
in the moon's orbit
where the moon is located
between the sun and earth.
Solar eclipses don't happen
every new moon though.
Most of the time,
the moon, earth and the
sun are not lined up.
This is because the
plane of the moon's orbit
around earth is at a
different angle than the plane
of Earth's orbit around the sun.
This means that the moon's
shadow is usually too high
or too low to hit earth
and cause an eclipse.
Total solar eclipses won't
be visible from earth
in about 600 million years.
This is because the moon's orbit
is gradually getting bigger
with the moon moving
about four centimeters
away from earth each year.
So one day the moon will
appear to be too small
in the sky to entirely
block the sun's light.
Total solar eclipses take place on earth
every 18 months or so,
but sometimes they're only
visible from the middle
of an ocean or a desert.
If you're curious
about when the next total solar
eclipse will happen near you
look it up online.
Scientists are able to calculate
when solar eclipses will
happen centuries in advance.
So you can start planning far ahead.
Personally, I'll need to travel
if I want to see a total
solar eclipse anytime soon
because the next one visible
in my hometown is on September 14th, 2099.